so one of the things that's interesting
is mormons and masons often get
connected because joseph smith was a
mason
um he became a first-degree mason and he
says right in his journal the number of
masons grew dramatically in the navajo
lodge
eventually growing to some 1 500 members
hey everybody welcome back to led live
today we're going to talk about the
topic of
mormonism jason here is going to share
with us
is the church of jesus christ of
latter-day saints
really the church of christ find out on
this episode of
led live
[Music]
light exposing darkness boy you guys are
in for kind of a treat today because
uh jason here is going to come and share
some of his childhood expertise on the
subject
and uh you know i know a lot of people
that actually have questions about
mormonism what do they really believe
and i even have questions about it like
i actually don't know that much about
them so i'm kind of excited to hear what
you have to say
um you know there's some things that i
i'm sure
going to be shocking but uh nonetheless
uh
i i want to really learn about this
subject um but before we get into that i
want to share with you guys
a couple of ways that uh we support our
ministry here at little light studios
we have t-shirts you guys have probably
noticed this because we've mentioned it
every single show
but every single week pretty much we
upload a new t-shirt
uh and we've got an awesome graphic
designer over here michelle does a lot
of our graphics for them
and so very excited about some of these
t-shirts if you guys
would like to support our ministry
that's one way check them out you can
look at teespring
or you can go to littlelightstudios.tv
and check us out that way
we also have stickers a lot of people
ask us you know about
wanting to support the ministry and put
a little advertisement on their water
bottles or their
computers or something like that so
check out some of our stickers
we are very much so trying to encourage
everyone to be
a witness for those around and sometimes
a simple thing like a sticker can do
something like that
so thanks for also for our patreon
donors you guys are awesome
and uh we we we just love you guys to
death you guys have
enabled us to be able to do this show so
thank you for that and everybody that's
jumping on and becoming new patreons for
us thank you guys so much for seeing the
value of
what it is that we're doing so we hope
and pray that you'll continue to do that
and we just really thank you and may god
bless you guys for for being generous
with us
um jason tell us a little bit about this
like how how did
why why did you um
well i'm sure we're gonna get into the
why but give us the background a little
bit of
of how you grew up in this faith yeah so
i was born into the church of jesus
christ of latter-day saints
my mom raised me that way went to church
every sunday
did the mormon thing where you get
baptized eight years of old according to
scripture
started going and doing temple work
doing the baptisms for the dead
all these types of things until my
turbulent teen years i ended up leaving
the church so
i ended up going out and kind of messing
my life up pretty good which maybe we'll
get to another point
um in the story but uh it was only after
i left that i really began to take a
closer look at mormonism
and what they actually taught and
rationally think through it
interesting interesting so when you left
it wasn't just leaving mormonism was
kind of like leaving the faith all
together
i don't believe in god it kind of was i
kind of love god it wasn't necessarily
just leaving the church
the church didn't really welcome me so
when i started smoking
for example doing a little bit of
drinking i felt guilty
uh like many uh the wood that there's a
lot of rebellion often in that age and
so i went to my bishop i confessed my
sins
was hoping for some forgiveness and he
said i was a bad kid and i was not
welcome in the church and he didn't want
me to be a bad influence on the others
wow so when he cut me off when he was
pretty harsh on me i was like okay i'm
out
yeah i'm good so i'll go find some other
way to make myself happy
it didn't work very well but i tried the
church is supposed to be a hospital
right you come in
they're supposed to help you it's like
not well if you're all
fine and dandy then you can be a part of
the church you know but
well it didn't work that way now that's
not everybody's experience but uh that
that was mine it was just one of the
ways that
it seemed i was led in that it pushed me
further down until i hit bottom before i
looked back up
well i'm interested to hear what you say
that you found out when you took a look
at mormonism in general like
what what are some things that just
seemed like a red flag or
yeah there was a lot i think it started
partly with my wife when i got married
she was like so what do you believe and
she would ask questions i was like
i don't know i don't know i just know
what we believe but i couldn't tell you
why or where it comes from
i didn't really understand it very well
and so i really started looking into it
and
it was interesting i think everybody
should examine their
faith no matter what church you're
involved in right because there are a
lot of
uh let's just call them traditions that
we
accept we we get programmed as little
kids right
i grew up in the church you know you
grew up the church you grew up at a
church
different churches and all sorts of
stuff that we all grew up in but
it's like you you you put this stuff in
and then if you never come back
at it and look at it what does the bible
really have to say
on this topic then it's easy to be
really led
in a bad direction so yeah i'm excited
to see
well and you guys are not the only ones
um you guys probably remember a few
years ago when romney was running for
president
yeah a lot of people got a lot of
interest because they were like who are
these mormons
you know who who are they what do they
believe what's going to happen if this
guy becomes president so they started
doing a bunch of research
and so one of those was pew forum if
you've ever heard of them and so they
had some interesting things
for example they asked
in an open-ended question what one word
best describes the mormon religion
in society in america and they said the
most commonly offered word is cult
other common responses are positive to
scripture such as good or good people
and family or family values which quite
honestly if you just sit back and think
about that that's a kind of a perplexing
picture we've got some really good
people with great family values yeah
they're cold
yeah wow it's kind of an interesting it
doesn't seem like the two match but this
was the
showing the confusion about who these
people are
um and so what they believe and so
you're not the only ones i looked into
it
um some more of the study showed like
six in
ten mormons so the mormons themselves
say that the american people as a whole
are
uninformed about them nearly half
46 say that mormons face a lot of
discrimination in the us today
which is higher than the percentage that
say the same about blacks at 31
atheist 13. two-thirds 68 percent say
that american people as a whole do not
see mormonism
as a part of mainstream american society
and when asked to describe in their own
words the most important problem
facing mormons live in the united states
cite mis perceptions about mormonism
discrimination
lack of acceptance in american society
and like so they feel like
you don't get them you don't understand
them and i think even within the church
sometimes i didn't know that i
fully understood them um and so it's
it's a normal thing to try and struggle
with your beliefs
but i think it's a it's something we all
have to do
you need to struggle with what you
believe and figure out why
so it probably just drives you to stay
in that bubble too if you don't feel
like anybody else understands you then
you're surrounded by only people that
you know how to identify with you right
yeah everybody wants to be around people
that
get them and think like them and act
like them and speak like them and so
you know this is normal and so that's
which would reinforce the cult
kind of yeah they're called perceptions
correct when i think of a cult i think
of like there's a film that uh
is coming out yeah jojo's right yeah
that's probably the most famous one
but there's a film that's coming out
that like they all go into the mountains
oh yeah it's like this mid-summer
mid-summer or something like that you
know i mean that's just kind of what i
think of when i think of cold but don't
drink the kool-aid yeah yeah exactly you
know you think of these like crazy
people that are leading all these people
completely astray
um but you know here it's like you know
they have a health message right they
live pretty healthy i mean they look
pretty conservative so to say
um yeah they witness they go
door-to-door right it's a good thing
right so yeah so one of the questions we
have to ask ourselves well who are they
that's the question i'm asked all the
time so what do they believe
is really the question and so as i dived
into that
um one of the most common questions i
get so are mormons really christian
right um that's an interesting question
it depends on how you define that
um so different people look at it
differently obviously if the majority
thought they were cult they might not
see it in that light so it depends on
how you define it
they mormons would say yes it's right in
our name where the church of
jesus christ so therefore we are
christians isn't that self-explanatory
right
so uh but you have to kind of look at
how people
see it so 97 of mormons describe
themselves as christian they see
themselves as christian
interesting though like growing up in
southern utah when i was there
if you said you were christian that
meant you were not mormon
because um there was if you were mormon
you would say you were
mormon right you wouldn't say you were
christian because it's a
it's another way of identifying
themselves which creates further
confusion
yeah so but they do see themselves as
christian
um they say 51 of non-mormons believe
mormonism is a christian religion
if you're white and evangelical then
it's a lot higher that you don't think
they are 47
and so they have some interesting
statistics on it 17
just don't know according to the the
research that went out at that time
so um and it's interesting how we
interact um i don't know about you guys
you ever had mormon show up on your
doorstep knock on the door
i always invite them in because one of
the things that happens is they're out
there trying i mean these are
19 20 year old people out there
you know putting themselves out there
whether they're guys or girls you can
have both
um but they they say 50 of mormons say
that evangelical christians are
generally
unfriendly towards them interesting so
it's interesting that if we are supposed
to be
christians wouldn't you think we're the
most loving and kind people towards
everybody
right but according to mormons they say
no you're not half of you are quite me
and i believe that i see comments from
people and stuff and they just
like they they almost attack mormons you
know and yeah
i think we should be loving and say like
like scotty said i'll invite them in and
have a conversation and i'm like what do
you believe about that what do you think
about this verse and
yeah usually a conversation goes to well
that
that book the bible's been translated a
lot of times why don't you just read the
book of mormon and see what you think
about it
and that's where i'm kind of like well i
want to i want
all my beliefs to come from the bible so
you know i'm never ugly or nasty about
it i just
tell them i believe the bible and if you
can prove it from here
then we can talk but i found it
interesting i
invited them in a number of times in my
current house um and so that'd be
interesting
i usually don't give the full disclosure
of who i am because i'm a pastor
they used to be mormons so that usually
intimidates them right right
but i would give them water if they
needed i would give them granola bars
and i found it kind of funny because
they liked that friendliness and that i
give them food because everybody likes
food so
they kept coming back with their friends
yeah yeah like they came in two or three
times hey you got any more of those
granola bars you know
you know be nice right so they find a
lot of people
aren't nice um 20 21 of mormons think
evangelical christians are neutral like
you're not nice but you're not me
right right and then they only friendly
only 18
of mormons thinks evangelical christians
are friendly wow
you know what's interesting is is the um
as i think about that i've talked with
many people about mormons and they
almost always say the same thing
they're the nicest people you would ever
meet right
so they're really doing a great job
on their on their side it's everybody
else that's
it's how people are responding to them
yeah because they think you know mormon
shows up at my door
they want to convert me which is
probably true right
but why do you need to feel threatened
about that if you're secure in your own
beliefs
i know they want to try to convert me
but i'm trying to convert that yeah
i would like try to pull a pull a fast
foot on them
yeah so um it's interesting if you're
gonna actually look at mormons there's
different
types if you will and now this is
stereotyping so forgive me
anybody out there keep in mind as i talk
about mormons i'm talking about my
family
these are people i love dearly these are
people i want in the kingdom of heaven
so
don't take anything i say as harsh
that's never what i mean
um so is the majority of your family
still mormon
uh yeah in fact i think i technically
am still mormon because they've never
removed me from the book so
that's interesting so i i still
technically kind of am but
there's citizenship stuff like that um
you're good to go man you're gonna make
it
yeah yeah i'm gonna be all right so i
just want to cross all my t's no
i'm not advocating to baptize in every
church then you'll be arrested
um but there are different types of
mormons and if you were like gonna talk
to them
they come across quite different and
there's a number of them
these are just common kind of terms that
are thrown out there so
i think it helps to get a little bit of
understanding so one of them is card
carrying mormon
it sounds it's a funny term to use but
the idea is when you want to go into the
temples the mormon temples that you can
see in the background of this image
like in salt lake city they need a
temple recommend
card so their bishop has to recommend
them based on good behavior
good payment church attendance there's a
number of things that qualify
when you do all those then you can go to
do temple work then you're like the
hardcore serious mormons
sounds like a secret society they're
going to sign up for all that social
numbering you know like no problems
are already out there so these are like
you're really serious
chapel mormons are like this is a term
just literature's got out there this is
the idea that
you just go to church but you know it's
basically culture
this is just what i grew up as so that's
about it
molly mormons is a term which my wife's
name is molly so i we always laughed at
it
these are it's interesting byu most
people have heard of
brigham young university there's a high
percentage of women that go there
specifically
to get married that's the point they're
not there to get a degree so much as
they are to get a return missionary
so they nicknamed them molly mormons
internet mormons is a
fairly new term that i've heard but this
is the idea like well you know
a lot of the things that the original
people that founded mormonism teach we
don't
buy that because we've read everything
that's on the internet but we're still
mormon
that's kind of this group jack mormons
is a pretty
common term this is like where you're
mormon in name only
and that's it so you i would still be
considered a jack mormont because i
don't go to church i don't have anything
to do with the mormon church
at all but they would still see me on
the books so therefore i'm a
jack mormont wow so and
flds is a totally different group so if
you heard about the people that all
the guy that had many many many many
wives um recently the gut was in waco
texas
that's not the regular group in fact one
of the things mormons get really upset
at
is judging them over polygamy which they
haven't been able or haven't been taught
to practice in a very long time so it's
so it's a select few that are actually
engaging in that
there are people that still do it for
sure um but it's
it's not the majority you're not
supposed to no it's not legal in utah it
is right
no it's still not legal in utah i
thought that's why another stereotype
but i've seen documentaries on this it's
illegal
it's illegal so what what happens
there's there's a lot of them that live
right on the border of arizona and utah
in these little pockets and they have so
many kids
that when they've tried to raid them
when arizona sent people in there it was
such a disaster and nightmare and they
couldn't figure out whose kids went to
who and
it was such a mess and such a pr just
nightmare
that they just leave a lot just a little
bit it's just it's just not worth it
so flds is a totally different group and
when you mix them
up it's almost offensive it's like this
is the offshoot that we don't believe in
so
why do you categorize us like the same
that makes sense so if anybody's in a
church and you have an offshoot that
goes a little crazy
that's how they view this which i think
is exactly how the devil treats almost
every church
oh yeah you know in our church there is
an offshoot group and there's always
these like
super fundamentalists like extremist one
southern baptist independent baptist
baptist right really semi
you know like you know i don't want to
be mean about it but just just
they've just got a whole different set
of belief systems but then that just
gets
applied to the whole group yeah you know
and that's just how the devil works
so he loves to mix truth and error
together that's right well something
that
something the devil does and god doesn't
so speaking of jim jones
he was a methodist pastor but you don't
look at methodists and say oh you must
be like jim jones you know
yeah it's just this confusion that comes
in
so it's interesting that mormons are
very
consistent in their beliefs though so
according to the
pew form uniformity of beliefs within
mormons so like 94
of mormons believe that the president of
the eldest church is a prophet of god
so there's a high percentage there's a
small six percent to say well i don't
know if he's a prophet
but the majority do 91 believe that the
book of mormon was written by ancient
prophets
and so therefore it's uh got viability
because of the prophets that it was
written by
by more than just joseph smith so joseph
smith translated
from the ancient prophet's writings
okay so that was before joseph smith
uh the mormon church in its in its
entirety didn't exist until joseph smith
joseph smith restored the truth
according to their belief so we'll get
to a little bit more of that in a minute
but
you know that's kind of where it comes
from 95 of mormons believe that families
can be bound together eternally in
temple ceremonies
so kind of one of the unique things i
guess
hindsight i look at it like it almost
separates more because they have
multiple layers in heaven
and multiple layers in layers of heaven
which you'd think would segregate people
more
so you need temple ceremonies to keep
them together
which is kind of you can have your
children sealed to you in the temple and
then you'll make sure they'll be with
you in heaven
and so they would argue that yeah this
is how we make sure we're families
together for eternity
so like there's some kind of separation
in heaven yeah there's celestial
celestial terrestrial i'll show you a
slide in a minute that
that demonstrates all this but the
interesting thing with that is
if you only got one heaven aren't you
all together but that would be
so that would be terrible if you're like
praying for your family to make it to
heaven
and then it's like oh they're in a
different realm oh you know they made it
but like oh
it really complicates things it kind of
muddies the waters if you will and so
there's that and then they believe god
the father and jesus christ are separate
separate physical beings
so um in the sense that they're not
trinitarian
in a traditional sense so and that's a
high belief too so they have
uh it's not one god in three persons as
most
christians would believe or evangelicals
would believe of sorts
but it's different gods if you will
interesting so this is where you start
getting to the question
of christianity um and some of these
things because they
redefine who jesus is right and if you
have multiple
gods so to say i mean isn't that just
kind of like defeat the
ten commandment number one so
it does get interesting um i think to
start if you're really going to address
mourinho you kind of
have to ask a little bit about who who
is joseph smith sure he's the founder so
like
in order to join the church there's not
a lot of things you got to say and do
but one of them is you got to believe
joseph smith was a true prophet
and he restored the true church and
that's kind of like
foundational it's kind of like in islam
you have to accept muhammad it's the
same thing so
joseph smith becomes this cardinal
central figure
that ties it all together so it's kind
of interesting so who was he
i mean i could give you a lot of details
on him but he's
the founder he was born in 1805 roughly
fourth of nine surviving children he
lived in palmyra new york for example
uh just a little bit about who he is um
there
um he claims to be have been visited in
september 21st by an angel moroni so if
you've ever seen the temple and there's
a little gold guy with a trumpet on the
top
that's yeah that's angel moroni now now
i used to live
by in san diego by the big mormon temple
that's down there and so it's a
beautiful yeah
beautiful temple i was so wanted to go
in there so bad and just see it
i gotta get your card yeah right yeah
you can go in before they're dedicated
though
interesting interesting that one was
there before before i moved there
um and correct me if i'm wrong but the
the trumpet on the top isn't he supposed
to like come to life and blow the
trumpet when jesus is coming
i've heard that okay that i don't know
if that's a church belief or that's just
like
outsiders making that up or something
like i don't know the quote on that one
per se
but uh yeah i heard that growing up yeah
interesting so some of some things
are really difficult to pinpoint where
the beliefs come from but they're
commonly held beliefs
if that makes sense so um so
the moroni told him of golden plates
which is important
they recorded the people's history
struggles wars final demise
and this was a new testament to the
gospel of jesus christ so
this is the book of mormon uh once it
was translated was on golden plates
would have been really heavy yeah but
golden plates are delivered
and it's inscribed on them and it's
giving a history of basically the native
american indians in north america
um it's north south central america so
it's it's an interesting story kind of
bringing in
who these people were and the kind of
the climax of the book of mormon
is the fact that jesus christ after the
resurrection at
an ascension came to america to these
people
and so this is where it becomes a
testament another testament of jesus
christ
interesting so that's kind of the
premise of the book of mormon um
so uh i took smith up to what's
called the hillcomore to receive the
plates which were then to be translated
use yerman thummaman this is in
scripture doesn't sound a bit like moses
it does
so there's some similarities you see in
the stories that's going through
so it ends up becoming the book of
mormon it's been through a number of
revisions so the original version
is not the same version that the
missionaries would hand you now wait a
minute
isn't that what you just said that they
said that the bible has been revised so
many times that they don't believe in
that
but is it is if if that is true then
you know what i mean like that book so
revised it is very interesting
and as you go into it there's a lot of
interesting background in this now i'll
hit a little bit more on scripture
because that's kind of foundational if
you're going to be
a christian or claim to be a christian
of any kind you've got to have a
scriptural base
right you've got to come back to god
said
or what else is it right then it's just
random beliefs
so one of the things that's interesting
is mormons and masons often get
connected because
joseph smith was a mason he became a
first-degree mason
and he says right in his journal the
number of masons grew dramatically in
the navajo lodge
eventually growing to some 1500 members
only
2072 in the rest of the united states so
one point
and this is uh this is a book written by
mormons that you're seeing on the screen
there
this is them trying to set the record
straight and i'm quoting right
from the book i'm in a footnote so
there's a lot of crossover
with freemasonry and mormonism the idea
of a lodge
and temple practices a lot of that seems
to have been derived or has
similar links or inspired or however you
want to put that from
joseph smith's masonic connection
so um that one's just interesting you
can see here it says in
to tuesday march 15 it says i officiated
as grand chaplain at the installation of
the navu lodge of freemasons at the
grove near the temple in the evening i
received the first degree
um and so if you go on so that was
tuesday march 15th now wednesday
march 16th next day i was at the masonic
lodge and rose to the sublime degree
so he jumped more levels and degrees
than anybody i've ever read about
what degree did he make it to you uh you
know that's debatable 32nd
i mean you you pretty much know what's
going on behind the curtain
30s there yeah so he jumped very very
rapidly
that's interesting um which is kind of
interesting and even
so this is a quote from jonathan
blanchard he was a former 33rd degree
freemason of the scottish rite
he gives an interesting insight he says
its legend in the 14th degree initiation
says that the real name of god was
lost till it was found by the masons
engraved on three
cornered gold plates in the ruins of
enoch who's a prophet in the book of
mormon
whether the mormon joseph smith who was
a mason took this story
of gold plates from this on or invented
a like legend of his own the two are
similar in origin nature and effect they
both utterly destroy christianity while
pretending
to favor and expand it so
this was from a mason he says you know
when i looked at when he looked at
mormonism he's like
well what joseph smith did it sounds
just like
what i learned in masonry so he's kind
of validating like
man mormonism must be real because it it
kind of lines up with what
yeah so there's a similar story there so
you know the reason why people say
they're tied and there's confusion
um it is because there are quotes out
there like this that show that he did
have those links
wow now um is this the same um
book of enoch like the book of enoch
that i see some people quoting out of
apocryphal the apocrypha that come from
mormonism uh there's this book of enoch
like do do mormons recognize the book of
enoch as canon
so sudafigura is a interesting topic um
and the apocrypha so pseudofigure that
means they had a false name on it
so enoch they don't believe the book of
enoch was really written by enoch
because it didn't appear to
way later and so there's pseudo figure
books so it's interesting because joseph
smith had to correct the bible
but when he was asked about the suit of
figuring he said there's nothing wrong
with it
wow and so he didn't correct it so it's
kind of interesting and that's right
in um doctrine and covenant what is the
other
i've never heard of that suitor for your
family sudafigura it's pseudo uh like uh
uh false figure uh signature
fault signature that's where it comes
from so there's a number of books out
there that are pseudofigura
meaning someone wrote it as though they
were someone else pretending to give it
credibility
yeah interesting so could it be
same thing but he said there's nothing
wrong with those brakes that's
wow so if you're wondering like the
structure how it works this is kind of a
an interesting just a background of how
it all works so you've got
congregational members and above them
you have bishops
and they're ward so you go to a ward and
you don't usually get to choose where
you go to church
it's it's it's designated by where you
live in your zip codes
there are single wards and there's
that's where you go to get
hooked up i guess but they they have
these types of places where you can go
if you're single but typically you don't
have a say in it
um and so and often if you see it a
mormon church there will be at least two
to three wards
in it and the church pays
outright for the entire building
different than what most churches
experience and so they build it
and then they go there and you're
assigned which ward you belong to
is there a warden so
i live in a pretty small town and we do
have a church of latter-day saints but
it's the only one i see so you're saying
there could be two or three
congregations with a hundred to 200
members in each
so one church could represent 600 people
oh that's interesting
so we don't often think of it that way
but they have it's kind of like a church
having multiple services
that's how they do it so they utilize
and capitalize on their um
buildings as best they can so and it's
interesting their design usually you
have the sanctuary and right behind us
is a big gym
so the kids can play basketball and
stuff but you can open a partitioning
wall and have extra seats for when you
are really full so they they do some
interesting things
um so if you were to look at this above
that you have stakes
presidents 70 a quorum of 70 like jesus
sent out to 70.
and then above that you've got 12
apostles
and these 12 apostles with two
counselors and the president or prophet
so it'll tell you right in here at the
death of the president the longest
serving member of the 12 apostles
becomes the president of prophet which
is kind of a fascinating thing so
in mormonism you always have a prophet
so god is always speaking
and he always has someone that's there
it's similar
in structure although they don't like
being compared to catholicism it's kind
of like a pope type
scenario where there's always one that
comes up
popes are elected whereas this is the
longest serving member
but they do have a very strong authority
in the church
more so than what you'd find most church
leaders founders type things so
they actually have the ability to
correct scripture
and things like this so one of the
things that makes it doesn't sound
catholic their theology is fluid
in in essence because it can evolve and
you can see this very clearly in the
idea that
polygamy was once allowed but then it
wasn't allowed
and so you have different doctrines
actually change and scripture changes
and i'll show you a couple of those
in just a little bit but this those who
get this um
like a cabinet just go on so doctrines
can and are frequently changed by the
prophet upon
a recep receptor reception of any new
revelation from god
that's moral relativism yeah so it's
it's constantly changing so it's
interesting when you get to mormonism
they would this picture says a lot if
you look at it it's a big no-no
ever since i was actually a kid i always
was taught
to take the bible and put it on top you
never put another book on top of the
bible
that's just that's just as a kid i
always grew up like that a lot of people
grew up that way so you always want to
keep the most holy count right there up
on the top so
it stacks in order that you have book of
mormon doctrine and covenants pearl of
great price these are the
trifold basic beliefs more of their
doctrines actually come out of the
doctrine covenants in many ways than
book of mormon and we'll see that in a
little bit but they would see
their scriptures overriding the bible
now this was something that's very
different than most christians so
most christians see the bible as like
yeah this is it this is where it's got
to come if you can show me in there i'm
good
like you said you wanted to come from
scripture from the bible for them
well you might not be able to trust the
bible and so this is
easiest scene article of faith kind of
like a statement of belief it says we
believe the bible to be the word of god
as far as it is translated correctly we
also believe the book of mormon
to be the word of god so when it comes
to mormons
they see that the translation um
it's got to be translated correctly so
in other words
a easy way to describe this would be if
you find something in the book of mormon
and the bible seems to contradict it
the right one is the book of mormon
because it's the most current revelation
and so you're not building from the same
foundation you can see how the devil
sets up even this topic of the
translation right
he's just tinkering with the translation
over here and the default that that
happens to
for whatever other groups that have this
kind of mentality
then it's all of a sudden you just kind
of topple down some of their beliefs
so and one of the things that perplexed
me a little bit is when i discovered
joseph smith actually translated the
bible and there's a joseph smith
translation
but they don't use that one oh that's
interesting so they used the king james
version which i've always thought was
kind of strange it's like if you've got
a corrected version and a corrupted
version why would you use the corrupted
version
right it never really made a lot of
sense to me but that's just the way it
was
and so we just went through it but there
there is a joseph smith translation and
you can google it pull it up
um it's out there some will use it but
the official
is the king james that's interesting so
it's kind of interesting
and if you look at the interpretation of
it so this is a history of the mormon
church
joseph smith said i told the brethren
that the book of mormon was the most
correct of any book on earth
and the keystone of our religion and a
man would get near to god by abiding by
its precepts than by
any other book so in other words he
clearly saw it as
higher than the scripture
martin harris he was one of the three
witnesses when they translated so when
he would translate it
he would speak it and then it would go
there so he explained the translations
like this so that
he describes the process in which gold
plates went to
paper copies he said by the eight of the
seer stone sentences would appear
and were read by the prophet and written
by martin and when finished he would say
written
and if written um correctly the sentence
would
disappear and another appear in its
place
but if not written correctly it remained
until corrected so that the translation
was just as the engraved on the plates
precisely in the language used now i was
going to ask that question because it's
like you know how much could you
actually write on two plates
unless they were like you know so yeah
there was a magical
process going they've got a way to work
around that so there was a workaround
you don't need a ton of plates
really you could just get one if the if
the words appear and disappear
wow and so it's kind of this mystical
way of interpreting it that's kind of
i mean how could you refute that you
don't need that belief system and if
this is true
every word was perfect wow
so why why the revisions so it's
interesting sandra tanner is a lady
she's related to brigham young she has a
ministry right in downtown salt lake
city she wrote a pretty self-explanatory
book entitled 3913 changes in the book
of mormon
wow so you begin to ask yourself okay
most perfect book
word for word 3913 changes
right so it kind of 3900 pages of it
so it's pretty remarkable i mean this is
just it kind of it's mind-boggling
that you could have that many
adjustments
it makes you and one of the things with
this is it makes you really go
can i trust scripture i mean can i trust
god
i mean if god's word can change right
what do we believe in
yeah and so this is one of the
challenges with it when i discovered
this i was like man
okay so if the book of mormon's been
edited if i
wrote a paper and someone told me i had
three thousand four thousand edits
i failed and think about think about
what the end of the bible says right uh
revelation
22 that talks about what if you change
if you change these words your blessing
if you remove it your blessing will be
removed something like that and then you
create it yeah there is a curse that's
attached to that
yes there is so it's right at the very
end of scripture
um so what's interesting is mormons will
quote this
and say if you pull them up on this
topic they'll say well daniel said that
there should you should close the books
and so they think that well if you have
any books behind the book of daniel then
you know you've at it so but revelation
wasn't written until
way later right so uh but it's
interesting they would even do this yeah
so what it reads this is revelation 22
verses 18 where i testify to everyone
who hears the words of the prophecy of
this book specifically the book of
revelation is what it's referencing here
if anyone adds to these things god will
add to him the plagues that are written
in this book
and if anyone takes away from the words
of the book of this prophecy god shall
take away his part from the book of
life from the holy city and from the
things which are written in this book
that's verse 19.
i mean that's a harsh that's serious
so it's interesting because you have to
if you're building on
a different foundation you want to make
sure your foundation's solid man or your
house will crumble
that's right so um one of their
apostles orson pratt put it this way and
this is their words
forgive me if it sounds a little harsh i
don't mean it that way but i'm just
quoting
the reference on how they viewed the
book of mormon and he said
the book of mormon must be either true
or false he says it's got to be one or
the other you can't really have
somewhere in the middle road
he says if true it's one of the most
important messages ever sent from
god to man affecting both the temporal
and eternal interests of every people
under heaven to the same extent
in the same degree that the message of
noah affected the inhabitants of the old
world
in other words when noah preached it was
life and death
right and so they're they're equating it
to the same way but
they actually go on said to say if it's
false
they said it is the most cunning wicked
bold
deep laden impositions ever palmed upon
the world calculated to deceive and ruin
millions who will sincerely receive it
as the word of god
ouch so these are their own words it's
like
it's got to be one or the other so it's
really important if you have a friend or
family that's mormon
and they're believing in the book of
mormon even by their own beliefs
this is this is the breaking point if
you believe this it has a huge impact if
you don't believe it has a huge impact
so he says the nature of the message of
the book of mormon is such that if true
no one can possibly be saved and
rejected so if you don't accept it
you're not saying so the only people
that are going to go to heaven are
mormon
in a sense yes what about all the people
that were before the mormon church
that's why you need baptisms for the
dead and other things
so it becomes a necessity
is it true that a woman can't get to
heaven unless she marries a mormon
man that's complicated but in a sense
yes
so um when you get married you're given
your heavenly name
and the adamic language um the language
of adam
and each are given their own name but
the husband is given the wife's name so
that he can call out her name in the
resurrection
wow wow so if you're a single woman you
just there's no chance
uh there's different things um there's
different options and alternatives
sometimes they can even be sealed to
someone that's passed and other
different things so that they can still
get
married they have loopholes for all of
that but it's
it's kind of complicated it's not very
common i don't even think most mormons
would be very aware of it
but they're out there so looking at it
says
if it's true no one can possibly be
saved and rejected but if false no one
can possibly receive it and be
saved meaning they themselves would all
be lost
if it's not true oh wow that's that
that's what the apostle here saying he
says if after rigid examination be found
in imposition or false
it should be extensively published to
the world as such so
one of the things that's happened and
it's something i struggle with because i
i truly love mormon people my family and
all these people but
people have taken this as their marching
order to
bash mormons just slaughter
every terrible thing that's ever
happened in the history of the church
because
it's made of humans there's lots of
false things in there so they've taken
this
as a reason to be me yeah which i don't
believe that's what god's asking so
it's important that we look at what they
believe but it doesn't mean you be mean
about it
right which is actually why we wanted to
do this show in the first place so
i hope you guys know we're not bashing
we just really want to understand
this topic because i believe that we
need to reflect the character of christ
that's right we need to be loving and
kind to everyone regardless of what
their faith and
and is and if we can find a way to share
truth with them
then we should yeah so this is what
we're tackling this topic for
so i just want to point out a few of the
contradictions so if you're going to say
oh i believe in the book of mormon i
believe in their teachings i believe the
doctrine and covenants
there's some problems there and it's
kind of interesting
um here's one on the screen um
jacob chapter 2 verse 24 out of the book
of mormon says behold david and solomon
truly had many wives and concubines
which thing was abominable before me
saith the lord so
having multiple wives an abomination
okay you get later on jose smith has a
vision
doctrine and covenants and we know that
polygamy was a thing of their past and
so we get there
david's wives and concubines were given
unto him
of me by the hand of nathan my servant
and others of the prophets who had the
keys of this power
so you got to hold on a minute and say
does god give us
things that are abominable in his eyes
i mean you begin to see a different
picture of who god is if this is true
right i mean this is a very different
thing either that or you can say well
it was true back then and it was true at
this time but it hasn't been true during
all times and then truth is relevant
whenever god used the word abomination
in the old testament it was basically
like
this was you were to be put outside of
the camp you were yeah it was
excommunicated you were to be
even killed in certain circumstances so
never is an abomination
a you know easy thing no these are
strong words
um and so this is from their own
scriptures another one that you could
look up mormon
7 7 says in singing ceaseless praises
with the choirs above unto the father
and unto the son and to the holy ghost
which are
one god in a state of happiness which
hath no end
well wait remember when we started that
the uniformity believes they don't
believe in the trinity
so the trinity is in the book of mormon
but it's not in the later writing so
you can see for example in doctrine
covenants 1 21 32
according to that which was ordained in
the midst of the council of the eternal
god and
all their gods before this world was so
there's multiple gods
wow so so now how did they rectify this
then
because if the book of mormon is like
you know even held at a higher standard
than the bible
and you were to show the mormon this and
say look there's three gods
i mean three that are one you know what
i mean like a trinity
would they how would they respond to
that and this is part of the challenge
on why
scripture keeps getting re-interpreted
interesting
wait no these two quotes come from the
same book or is it a book of mormon
doctrine and covenants two different
writings both by joseph smith
so how studied are mormons
on their own writings because there's a
lot of people
you know they get into a particular
denomination and they don't know
they don't really know i mean they know
the basics you know it's like i'm
baptist i know i'm saved once i'm saved
i'm always saved
god's grace you know and it's like
beyond that
there's some that don't know a whole lot
true if you were to like this would be
true of many mormons i know yeah and
that's what i wonder is it's like you
see these
you see these contradictions but most of
them probably aren't studying they
probably
haven't come across both they haven't
come across all of them or noticed them
for me um the difference was we claim to
believe in two different gods
that's very well known and taught to us
and then they
yet they tell you when they come to your
home if you've ever had a missionary
come to your home
they give you the book of mormon now the
book of mormon is going to contradict
that that's confusing
and so what happens is if if you don't
understand it
um you i was taught that i was i mean
and this is just a cultural thing and
maybe part of it was the
environment i grew up in or the the
culture was
you're not allowed to ask questions so
if you ask questions
you're doubting and if you're doubting
you don't have faith and whatever is not
of faith is
sin so we weren't allowed to question
these things and this is part of where
when i came into my current
understanding i love that i came into a
church that encouraged questions like
i just laid it on and i'm telling you
for years
i laid it on the pastor that helped me
into the church because i'm like
i need to understand this and i can
finally ask questions that's awesome
and so that's one of the things and
that's one of the reasons that some
people deem it a cult
well that sounds good because if you
can't question anything
yeah and like for example another way
this comes is like um
i know a girl that she was baptized
outside of the mormon church into
another christian denomination
she went to brigham young university her
parents found out about the baptism
center there
they confiscated all of her books that
weren't mormon they did random searches
and so they don't even want you to read
or have anything and in the same way
like if they come to your door and you
give them materials they'll take it and
smile but they're not supposed to read
it
wow so i began to these these were the
kind of experiences and testimonies of
friends that went on missions that i
heard as a kid that i'm like that just
doesn't seem right what are they afraid
of
yeah was the question that kept coming
to me what are they trying to hide from
me
because if i can't read stuff i mean
either it's true or it's not
either i can search it out and test and
see if it's true or i can't that's why
god says come let us reason come let us
reason again and
um always have a reason for what you
believe yeah so there's a lot of
biblical references to that we should do
this there's nothing wrong with that
david questioned
i mean you can read some of the psalms
where he's like man where were you what
were you doing and then by the time he's
done he's like what was me thank you for
being there
you know there's this real life
wrestling with god
kind of real life experience and so
we weren't really allowed to do that you
just another phrase we'd heard is thank
god we have a prophet or we wouldn't
know what to do that was another phrase
i heard amongst friends it was like
we need a prophet to lead us and guide
us or we would be lost yeah and there
matthew mark luke john daniel
those those don't count that's why i
always tell people when
when we're having these discussions or
we do seminars or whatever
you know they're saying well you you're
telling me i can't do this or i can't do
that and i still don't know i'm not
and do whatever you want to do i'm not
your mommy i'm not your daddy exactly
this is freedom to do whatever you want
to do i'm just telling you
you should consult god and ask him if
you should
not whether or not you can't we have
freedom as christians we can do whatever
right may not be the best choice and we
should be able to talk about it and
let truth come to the surface you know
that's the beauty of god is he allows
free choice
without free choice what is there right
so i mean god doesn't ever take the
freedom of choice away and so
when you take it away from someone
that's an oppression and an act of the
enemy not of god it would have been
interesting if eve would have been able
to consult god
oh wait she's schmidt hold on hold on
hold on
hold on i'm gonna go back i'm gonna
bring god over here and let's have a
little discussion about this together
it's interesting it's interesting that
you even bring it up because she was
already told not to go there right right
so god had already consulted her
and she acted against his will
intentionally right so when we do that
that's any time we do that
we're we're going on dangerous ground so
do mormons have like the base for what's
right and wrong like for example for
christians we have the ten commandments
and that's they would say it's the ten
commandments
um as well um because they they they
believe themselves to be very moral and
upright people
and most people would say that's true
when you meet them they're clean
they're upright i look mormon i know
what you know
but you know this idea that uh they
would base it by that
they just have their own interpretation
of it if you will
and so um and we'll get to a little bit
more of that
let me show you just a couple more um to
give you just to show you how this goes
so
here's an example and this sounds just
like scripture this is third nephi 3
20 from the book of mormon it says turn
all you gentiles from your wicked ways
and repent of your evildoings of all
your lines and deceivings and of your
whoredoms and of your secret
abominations and your idolatries and
your murders
and the list goes on and come unto me
and be baptized in my name that you may
receive a remission of your sins and be
filled with the holy ghost
that you may be numbered with my people
or of the house of israel
sounds very scriptural doesn't it yeah
so notice i've highlighted one word in
here
if you've murdered you could come to him
and get remission of sins
well that's not true in the doctrine
covenants so what's interesting is this
becomes an unpardonable sin
and there's a number of them depending
on which property you're reading so
doctrine covenants 42 18 says
and now behold i speak unto the church
thou
shalt not kill and he that kill shall
not have forgiveness in this world nor
in the world to come
oh wow so so what does that mean for
military
and and is the word kill meaning like
like you did you killed somebody
so this is where interpretation is a big
thing but i don't know when i read these
two things i say
that doesn't make sense right how do you
how do you
how do you actually deal with this as a
mormon if you're actually reading your
scripture and studying it like you're
supposed to
right just like they tell you you should
do what do you do when you come across
this so
if i was in a war and i killed someone
in
duty and service for my country does
that mean i'm lost
right i have no forgiveness in this
world nor in the world to come i mean
that's pretty
intense what about involuntary
manslaughter yeah so i mean wow
the bible had involuntary manslaughter
they had cities of refuge they could go
to all these different things god had
things in place there was always
forgiveness
david would not be saved he who asks for
he's faithful to forgive us right yeah
first john like yeah
and this is only people i mean because
you get into the whole realm and
morality of like what if it's a bug what
if it's an animal
or what if it's a something else one of
the things i i
often do is just get like for example i
used david consistently before with that
david is the most revered king of israel
you could say okay well he murdered a
bunch of people in war well what about
uriah
right yeah that was pretty evil yeah
is he not going to be in heaven i mean
this is where all of a sudden
all of scripture has to be reinterpreted
and this is where which do you trust so
the confusion babylon confusion
all comes in moses killed in egyptian i
mean tell me who didn't
yes samson yeah he's killed lots of
people just because he wanted their
garments
so this is where just for me this was a
very confusing
dynamic to grow up in um so i i heard
things but they contradict things but i
couldn't ask questions and i wasn't sure
what to do
and so it this is why i become the true
shall set you free
right this is my experience when i
actually looked into everything and came
out of it and really
found the god of scripture sola
scriptura
wow so what's interesting is they
actually believe to an extent it's okay
to lie
if it's not to the church so
let me preface that a little bit that
sounds a little harsh and extreme but
let me give you an example and this is
straight from the prophet
of the mormon church he was the prophet
when i was growing up so he was
interviewed by time magazine you can
pull it up that's time magazine august
4th 1997
uh he was formerly interviewing the
former president and prophet of the lds
church gordon b hinckley
the question was asked is this the
teaching of the church today that god
the father was once a man like we are
to which his response was i don't know
that we teached it
i don't know that we emphasize it i
haven't heard it discussed for a long
time in public discourse
i don't know i don't know all the
circumstances under which that
statement was made i understand the
philosophical background behind it but i
don't know a lot about it and i don't
know that others know a lot about it
meaning i don't know i don't know i
don't know right this is the president
this is the president okay so you should
know so you should know and this is a
this is a very common catch phrase
god the father was once a man like we
are so
um when you this is again august 4 1997.
so um on another occasion hinckley was
asked the question don't lds believe
that the
that god was once man he applied i
wouldn't say that there was a little
couplet coined as man is god once was
as god is man may become now that's more
of a couplet than anything else
but the implications of that phrase is
a man can become god god right
yeah that's the easter idea well go back
to the first
lie in the book of genesis you shall be
like
god and so
it's interesting because that was 1997
so three years earlier
three years when he's speaking to the
general conference of
mormons he's there so this is october
this was in his main discourse to the
church he says the whole design of the
gospel
is to lead us onward and upper to
greater achievement even eventually to
godhood
this great possibility was annunciated
by the prophet joseph smith in the king
fallen sermon
and emphasized by president lorenzo snow
is this grand and incomparable concept
as god
now is man may become wow his keynote
sermon
was on this topic but when asked by time
magazine says i don't know
i don't think we teach that wow so and
this was
just before that so it's super confusing
because he could say one thing
because they don't have the same spirit
as we do and so
it like i say this is just it's riddled
with confusion
um as you look into it and i'm not going
to go too far into it
and one of the things that um i've i'll
often bring out
when i'm talking about this it's really
difficult to define all of their beliefs
um and there's a lot of confusion on it
so i took a statement this is right from
mormon newsroom.org
org so the official lds church website
it says not every statement by made by a
church leader past or present
necessarily constitutes doctrine
fair we could say that any church could
say that that's fair a single statement
by a single leader on a single occasion
represents a personal
the well-thought opinion but is not
meant to be officially binding for the
whole church
so with divine inspiration the first
presidency the prophet in this two
councillors the quorum of the apostles
twelve apostles the second highest
governing body of the church counsel
together to establish doctrine that is
considered consistently proclaimed
in official church publication so this
is the key point
the doctrine resides in the four
standard works of scripture the holy
bible
the book of mormon the doctrine
covenants and the pearl of great price
official declarations and proclamations
and the articles of faith
some doctrines are more important than
others and might be considered core
doctrines
so what happens with this is i try to
address some of the more core doctrines
so scripture obviously is foundational
and i'm quoting as i was giving you
references of where they contradict from
those two
official standard works by the church
based on their official website so i'm
trying to give if there's a mormon
listening right now
um i love you bro sister whoever you are
but um
you need to read it you need to study it
and this is what they tell you to do and
so when
you need to ask the questions sometimes
and really look at what they say
you can pause the video and look at the
reference below
put links in the description that's
right all right so
i want to address some of these unique
teachings because i believe they take
the teachings
most people understand in scripture and
it kind of flips them upside down
have you ever seen that i've seen your
videos i know you understand that so
where the enemy takes a true truth and
he flips it upside down
that's right and so so it's the same
lingua the same players
it's just that their their context is
messed around so
you you kind of hear the buzz words or
you hear the oh wow it must be christian
but it
sounds similar but they end up reversing
and so
for me this was very problematic um and
this is straight from the pearl of great
price the book of moses
god planned and wield sin for mankind
god wanted us to sin wow now just pause
on that for a second
just puzzle everything yeah that's huge
the implications of that
is just that it's god's fault you can
immediately see
that they're placing the blame i mean
that that that's a satanic view of
of mind who is this god right god had
nothing to do with sin that's why we
call it the mystery of iniquity
we don't understand it you will never
understand it because to simply
understand it gives a license to it
and so basically like that is that's
alarming
to me i'm gonna give you a couple quotes
because that's a bold statement so let
me give you a few references
so notice in this one and in that day
adam blessed god and was filled the day
he sinned
and began to prophesy concerning all the
families of the earth saying blessed be
the name of god for because of my
transgression my eyes are open and in
this life
i shall have joy pause where did the joy
just come from
transgression wow and again
in the flesh i shall see god and eve his
wife heard all these things and was glad
saying were it not for our transgression
we never should have
had seed children and never should have
known good and evil and the joy of our
redemption and the eternal life which
god giveth unto all the
obedient so now you're going to get
works in there a bit well wait in the
beginning of the bible yeah
the bible didn't not say god created man
and eve to
be fruitful and multiply before you get
to sin yeah
prior eating the faith and ask them to
be obedient
yes so you're reinterpreting all of
scripture here
yeah so here in this case they're
basically stating that if we wouldn't
have sinned we wouldn't have known
salvation
so therefore it's a good thing that we
sin so that we can experience salvation
creation
but if you never sinned you didn't need
salvation right right
now now listen to the mind trip of this
because
you know truth often lies in our error
often lies
very close to the truth right now it is
true
that we have a close connection to god
simply because we have sinned meaning we
have an opportunity that literally the
rest of the universe
we have a special place we have a
special place because now jesus
looks like us will forever live as a
human uh
god and and will ever retain you know
his human form
and so it's like we have this special
opportunity
but this just really kind of tinkers
this is quite different
yeah um so it just totally changes it
for me
you start asking the question you mean
what if someone was
heaven forbid raped god wanted that
right i mean seriously what kind of god
is this i mean this totally redefines
god in my mind
if you experience that if god wanted sin
god wanted every bad thing that's ever
happened to you
to happen this is not the same god i
find
in the bible and so this is why i bring
this one out this is very unique
in that i don't see it anywhere else but
it's very key in
understanding so here's a couple of
these and you'll notice the reference on
this
so these are answers to gospel questions
and the gospel student manual so this is
what they give student missionaries
when the missionaries go out so i wanted
to look at okay this is what they're
teaching this is what they're teaching
them
so because this is in more of a catechol
type style where they ask question and
answer which makes it a little more
helpful to get a plain answer
so here it says did they adam and eve
come out in direct opposition to god
and his government no but they
transgressed a command of the lord
wait what hmm so and through that
transgression
sin came into the world the lord knew
that they would do this and he designed
that they
should so rules are made to be broken so
it's just super confusing because now
we're supposed to sin right but if we
don't if we sin we need salvation but we
have to have good works to get saved and
so
right
it's almost like obedience is an
opposition to what god has for our life
well the goal of their gospel is
different than the goal of our gospel
and we're going to get to that in just a
second because that's one of the next
ones
but it's interesting so notice he says
did they come out against his
but his government would the answer was
no but they transgressed a command of
the lord that was brigham young
when you get to joseph building smith it
says so really it was not in the true
sense a transgression of a divine
command
now that now they're backing on that
adam and eve made the wise decision in
fact the only decision that he could
make
it was the divine plan from the very
beginning that man should be placed on
earth and be subject to mortal
conditions
and pass through a probationary state
romans
what shall we say then shall we continue
in sin that grace may abound
i mean his answer is very plain
certainly not how god
did i descend live any longer in it i
mean there you go
and this is where you're going to find
either you're basing your beliefs out of
the bible
you're basing your beliefs out of mormon
teachings and their scriptures
and so you can't really have the two
it's always perplexed me that they kept
the king james version even
as a part of their scripture because
they don't actually believe it
they just take bits and pieces of it so
that they
sound more christian well well exactly i
think i think the devil was really smart
in the dark ages
because he basically could not snuff out
the bible
he realized the harder he fought against
it the more everybody popped up so then
he said you know what i'm gonna put a
bible in everybody's home
and they're not even going to read it
i'm going to put a bible in everybody's
home and they're not even going to
believe it
it'll literally sit on the table on the
desk and you don't even know what's in
it
that's right either that or he'll give
him additional scripture that'll just
thoroughly confuse them so here's a
question if you
go to a a service a mormon service
is the majority of what they read out of
the book of mormon or some other book
book because
pearl or great price it depends on the
church i mean quite frankly it's hard to
categorize an entire denomination
right that's pretty tricky to do so it
depends on who the bishop is
at that church and so they i mean they
have some things that are standard so
usually the first sunday of every month
is
fast sunday so you're all supposed to
fast you have a
communion type sacrament service whereas
water
and leavened white bread every single
time don't get into the confusion of the
symbols
but they would do that and then they
would have testimonies testimonies
typically being
i believe in justice miss a true prophet
i believe in the restored truth and
i love and then they start crying and
maybe they had a few more words it's
really short
and a bunch of people get up at least
that was my experience with the
testimonies
um another major thing is they believe
in the pre-existence of mankind
which no other church to my knowledge
teaches because this totally
changes everything it's kind of like the
idea we believe that
god has always existed that jesus
existed before he came here so they just
take this and mean that for
everybody in a sense so this kind of
we'll get into the significance of it in
just a second there's a whole bunch of
references i could give here
there's a bunch of on the screen ye were
also in the beginning with the father
that which is spirit even the spirit of
truth man was also in the beginning with
god the elements are eternal and spirit
and element inseparably connected
receiving a fullness of joy
so we've always existed man was also
in the beginning with god um the
president joseph milden smith he said
the latter day saints are the only
people in the world as far as my
knowledge goes who have a clear and
distinct doctrine in regards to the
question
where did we come from why are we here
and where are we going i believe we are
the only people in the world who believe
in the pre-existence of the human family
wow and that's interesting that you said
that
you said that and then that quote said
that but i just want to throw this out
there for anybody who might
be a fan of this preacher or whatever
but there's a guy named jesse duplantis
who's a big evangelical preacher
he had um a sermon that was you can buy
it on dvd
it's called uh close encounters of the
god kind and he had this vision where he
went to heaven and
very moving like if you hear it it
sounds so good and
he describes heaven real vividly and
so he had this near-death experience and
he says he met
these baby ghost-like beings in heaven
that were saying um i want to go to
earth like they
they were begging to be created as
humans and get to live as a human
he holds those i saw those little souls
at the throne of god they look about
this big
like they had a little nightgown on them
and they would
fly they could fly and they would fly
into that presence of jehovah
and i'd hear him saying can we be a
spirit can we be a spirit
would you send us to the earth so we can
be a spirit we want to be a redeemed
person
can we be a spirit so now i know how god
sends these babies
they look like little little bitty
things about this big
they just go out of the breath of god
that's that's the belief of this church
that's weird yeah so here is the diagram
to give you a visual
illustration of this that i grew up with
so in the realms of deity in the spirit
life
was your first estate and heavenly
father with one of his wives gives birth
to spirit babies
that's you um so
yeah we're not going to get into the
nuances of that
but from there from birth you get to the
second estate which is earth
and from there you've got three
different paths and these are your
levels of heaven so you've got a
telescope kingdom terrestrial kingdom
celestial kingdom the celestial has at
least three levels in it
and so to just give you a brief way the
low way it says
the people that go there are the
dishonest the liars the sorcerers the
adulterers and the whoremongers
and they detour a thousand years in hell
and then they still make it to heaven so
there's going to be sorcerers adorcers
adulterers and whoremongers in heaven so
everyone makes it to heaven
that's pretty much the way it comes
across i mean i mean anybody
that sounds pretty good right does
anybody
what a great religion well it gets
better
um so anybody essentially that isn't
mormon so those that are good moral
people
but don't have mormonism you go to the
second level
and they they have the glory of the
stars the moon and the sun
that's kind of how they're described but
if you want to go to the highest levels
of heaven
there's a whole bunch of things you have
to do legalism
um i don't like calling it that because
that has a lot of
jargon that comes along with that but
the idea here is you have to have faith
repentance baptism holy ghost okay good
things right
we all should have those morality you
should be a moral person you should be
loyal you should be
tithing you should be words of wisdom is
their health message and duty to the
church
and then if you want the highest level
you have to get married in the temple
because when you get married in the
temple that's how you become
exalted or become a god yourself wow
okay so gonna take it to a whole new
level when you go there so you actually
end up becoming a god
and you get to make your own creation
and then you get to populate it
wow so everybody gets their own earth so
there's some interesting people have
called it a sex cult and all kinds of
different things out there because of
these beliefs now
it is what it is this is this is
straight from them this is from
the salt lake city um church this is
what i grew up with this was a very
common
way of describing what they call the
plan of salvation
wow so you're a free agent to choose
which path
you take but ultimately they all go to
heaven there's one exception
and the one exception is on this is a
little bit clearer slide for me this was
a disclaimer this is from a um
someone that is an anti-mormon person so
disclaimer
um this one is someone that didn't like
us so in our pre-mortal life we were
intelligences first we were eternal
matter
i don't know what that is or how you
define that they don't know much about
it
then spirit children are born of god and
wife and that's where you get the first
estate now the exception here is
one-third
was cast out becoming evil forces to
earth no chance to get a body so catch
us
the devil and his angels their curse was
no physical body
hence no progression you can't have seed
you can't have children and that's the
real consequence
so just to back up just a quick sec now
imagine
what it would feel like as a mormon
woman that can't have children
right something's wrong with you you
can't have her feet
so the angels that have bodies they
can't have children
this is where it gets real complicated i
mean so there are angels with
some of
i don't know that they answer and i'm
not really going to answer but the idea
here is you need a body to progress
yeah if you're going to progress and so
when you die you go to one of two places
it's
paradise that's where the cross thief on
the cross goes to paradise and that's
lds go there and they will teach the
people to go to spirit prison
aka hell and so when you're down there
they will come and the more
missionaries will talk to you in hell
and as soon as you accept mormonism
you can get out so wait there's more
there's mormon missionaries that they've
got to go do a mission like two years in
hell
and then i think you gotta like win that
i'm just saying
that way but that's i'm just saying so
it's belize or the other place i mean
yeah is there really people that go down
into hell to try to teach them the truth
this is this is after death okay
so this isn't during a physical life so
post-death
you go to paradise or you go to spirit
prison how do the people
in the spirit prison though learn about
mormonism because there's a missionary
that goes down to them
yeah yeah that's a credit assignment and
so
once they accept this is part of the
reason for baptisms for the dead because
you have to believe and be
baptized so how do you get baptized when
you no longer have a body
someone has to do it in proxy for you i
mean there's probably a lot of current
converts that way because if you're in
hell and somebody says i can get you out
of here you're probably going to
believe me yes i believe
it gets me out of here i'm good um and
so the first resurrection is
only the lds and they go through the
millennium
the people in spirit prison go straight
into the judgment
and so the second death according to
revelation
are the sons of perdition satan and his
followers so this is the people that are
mormon
and leave so if you're mormon and leave
so
the reason i bring this up um
essentially is i i'm a warm on the left
um and so i know others that have left
and so the idea here is well can i even
be saved
and one of the things that comes up as a
challenge is technically
i'm still on their books wow i was going
to ask you about that so yeah to clarify
why have they not taken you off the book
so i requested it
and i know friends that have succeeded
in getting off it's about a two-year
process
it's not easy to get off the books if
you say you want out it's
you have to write a letter to your
bishop who sends it up the chain of
command and it takes quite a while
before you get out
now the reason being is they think they
are doing the most just and kind thing
yeah according to them so yeah catch
this if i'm mormon i would go straight
up to the celestial kingdom mormons not
married in the temple one of the bottom
two layers
if as soon as he approves that i'm a son
of perdition
i don't go to any your fate's in his so
the choice of removing a name off a
piece of paper is the difference between
me being
eternally dead or getting to one of the
highest levels of heaven
i mean that's that's like in their
theology this is the kindest most
merciful thing they could do now it's
difficult it took me a long time
to come to that conclusion because at
first i was just angry why won't you
take me off the books
and a lot of mormons go through that if
they leave they're like this is wrong
this is messed up how come you want i
don't believe in this and
they actually know i'm a pastor and they
don't seem to care
so maybe after they watch this they
might
but you know ultimately they're doing
what you have to
almost zoom back and see their theology
to recognize where they're coming from
their heart i believe is as pure as it
could be within their
theological understanding almost like
pulling the trigger like they're like
oh i mean how heartbreaking to yeah
and i have to say as a pastor now if i
was in his position
if i really believed that if someone
cuts came to me and said
i'm out i want out of your church if i
approved it and i thought that meant
they were eternally dead
i would seriously hesitate signing that
piece of paper and so you can't
fault them for that and so part of why i
bring this up is for those that have
left because you need to understand that
they are trying to be loving and
merciful
in the best of their knowledge so people
can only
operate within the light that's been
shown to them and so in that sense
they're not doing something wrong
um it is the loving and merciful thing
even if we don't agree with it
yeah so important kudos to the mormon
church for trying to follow their
beliefs right
um so some of the significance of this
whole plan of salvation
is it affects everything temple work for
the dead the genealogical work
so if you have to be mormon to be saved
you need to know everybody that has ever
lived before you that wasn't mormon
right
so guess who the greatest genealogical
databases are go through in the mormons
so that's what they go through so they
have huge record database if you've done
genealogy
i'm sorry that the mormons got that so
so is um are they in the same belief
system
of the world being around 6 000 years
old
i was taught i could believe in creation
or evolution oh wow wow whichever way
you like right
yeah because they're definitely opposing
views you know i've heard people in the
church strongly say one way or the other
and i didn't they didn't emphasize it
very much so because of that i was led
to believe it really didn't matter
um and so it's yeah you're you're
getting
a little off on something that probably
they wouldn't see as important
so wouldn't you need a logical work did
they like
fund start like ancestry.com like how
would they get
they did they funded it i mean that
makes sense like if they want to
get everybody to give you the
information a fascinating little fact
um i have no way to validate it but
there's there's a guy that wrote a book
on his experience um working for the top
quarters of the
headquarters of the mormon church and he
calls it you can find his book on amazon
he calls it fictitious but it's it's
based on
his experience so it's called the book
of mammoth
and he says the mormon church is the
richest organization on the planet when
it comes to liquidity
because of the organizations like
safeway albersons coca-cola i mean
there's all these myriads there's
there's tons of organizations that are
owned
by the church they own the majority
stockhold so
one of the things they did early on was
they took a different belief in
tithing than most people do so what they
did is they didn't pay clergy
they made them pay tithe and then they
invested it
so as they invested it when they were
investing millions of dollars back in
the 1800s guess what that made them
over 100 years right extremely wealthy
this is
i mean you've seen the temple can you
imagine how much one of those cost
right and they build them all over the
world for free no real gold
i mean you'd probably gold coated i'm
not gonna go up there and check it
so but it has a just a huge amount of
different things that this comes into
if you buy into these beliefs and it
just kind of changes everything
um so their beliefs on the fact that yes
we've always existed
you know freedom of choice is kind of
questionable in some of this stuff when
they get a choose in the afterlife
you get the idea that god wanted us to
sin
and you paint a very different picture
of who god is and so i let
anyone listening to this or anybody ask
me you determine whether they're
christian or not i'm just giving you the
facts on what they
teach as a church so
um baptisms for the dead are one that i
always get a lot of questions on because
they get the passage in this that this
comes from right out of
the bible so in corinthians paul
mentions people getting baptized for the
dead
now most theologians don't agree on
exactly what was happening there
it wasn't what mormons are doing we have
archaeology and all kinds of things that
we have no evidence that they were doing
what
mormons do with it it could have been
many things but it's
it's one of these very odd doctrines
because
um i've been baptized by immersion
hundreds of times
four dead people super confusing
um i was always trying to understand so
who are these people
you don't even know who they are i mean
you just really no idea
they're reading off a prompter screen
and so they were just going on i'm like
and i've literally had kings and queens
and people i'm like
you know what if this was hitler's right
hand man does he i mean
how do we know they converted i mean god
can't allow sin in heaven
or can he and you know all of a sudden
it's just this weird
sensation and often you have spiritual
encounters because of some of these
things because when you open yourself up
to the idea that spirits have always
lived
and always live post death
you have this idea of spirits coming and
visiting you is a common
thing are you going to touch on that i
will touch on that maybe
um just in in a short version i have had
more than one spiritual encounter one of
them was a dead brother or someone that
claimed to be my dead brother
and so this is a common thing and so
that i'll show you where that becomes
critical here in a little bit but
this idea of baptisms for the dead it's
a little strange to most christians we
find a bizarre
but it says the doctrines of the dead
according to brigham young says
is a great doctrine one of the most
glorious doctrines that was ever
revealed to the human family and there
are light glory power
honor and immortality in it um
the prophet wilford woodruff he's the
one that
undid polygamy he says i will hear say
before closing that two weeks before i
left saint george
the spirits of the dead gathered around
me wanting to know why we did not redeem
them
so now i'm just going to pause on that
one because that's kind of a big deal
surrounded by spirits but they're saying
they're not
saved so take the implication of that
these are lost
fallen spirits surrounding you
and somehow you as a human are going to
redeem them
wow so i mean it sounds like the power's
in your hands
yeah jesus so it's in us not god
and fallen spirits can surround us yeah
wow so i mean if you go into
the bible again you're going to have a
very different picture of this stuff
when
when the king saul went to a witch to
bring up a spirit it wasn't a good thing
no it wasn't samuel
no the devil and so you have these
scenarios where it's like
wow can you imagine how easily this
could prime someone
to be led astray yeah so i will tell you
from my experience when my brother came
to me or the person that claimed to be
my brother as a full-grown adult he died
as a child
you're gonna believe your sibling and so
no matter what anybody tells you and the
thing is is you couldn't discredit my
experience because that was my
experience
and if you tell me that was a devil i'm
angry at you because you just demonized
my brother
yeah and so it takes on a whole
different
emotional level in us as people when we
have someone
we're emotionally attached to and love
that comes to us
this is why it becomes so deceptive
because you're gonna believe them over
anybody else and it was the state of the
dead was one of the most common
um challenges that it was one of the
hardest things for me to grapple with
what scripture was telling me when i was
reading it because it was it
contradicted so much of what i grew up
with
and so but the bible is the bible i'm
going to take the bible's word off
that's right
there you know you can at least again
say by their own theology they're
again doing the most loving thing
according to their theory they're saving
people
because yeah they're they're trying to
be mormon to be saved we've got to go
back and do the genealogy and save them
so again you can't really fault them in
a sense but
what motives are their motives are good
and this is why they get categorized as
good
good people family family values they're
doing genealogy
they're very much about having their
family close to them
but colt you're right i don't know
right so this is this is a little bit of
where they come from if you're ever
curious
uh i just did pull up an image this is
what the baptismal tank looks like in
the basement of
a temple this was pre-dedication so this
is
you see the reference first kings there
that was solomon's temple
so it's modeled after the scriptural um
temple of solomon's temple
and then like the golden calf and this
is what solomon did that's what solomon
did
and so it sits up onto the round yeah
you read the account
there's yeah around around there at the
base of it it's probably the best thing
to do at the base of it
so first kings chapter 7
describes it so um there it says
and he made the sea of cast bronze ten
cubits from one brim to the other and it
was completely round so that's the
baptistery type thing
its height was five cubits and lined
with 30 cubits measured in circumference
below its brim were
ornamental buds um so you can see the
buds on the picture and circling around
with the way around the sea the
ornamental buds were cast in
two rows when it was cast and it stood
on 12
oxen three looking toward the north
three looking toward the west and three
looking towards the south
and three looking towards the east the
sea was set upon them and all their
backs
parts pointed inward so backs pointed
inward three facing in direction it's
straight out of scripture
but what are they made out of um i
believe these are just coded i really
don't know i mean did that say gold or
something i believe it's i thought it
was
bronze but it could be gold um i so it's
not really the golden cow
it's not really the golden cow they're
not worshiping it it's just sitting on
top
of it i guess yeah and the ox was a
sacrificial animal
so but that's that's where what it looks
like so you would go in there
how would work is they would say there
would be an elder there and you have to
wear special clothes in the temple and
everything and you go in and there and
he'd baptize you
in my name he'd give my name in the name
of the father the son and the holy
spirit
in before and behalf of whatever names
on the screen
and so and they would do this typically
i believe it's about 30
and they usually do it with young
children um
and then it stops at a certain age so
we'll get to that but this kind of comes
into this idea i mentioned my brother
so here is this is joseph smith in
gospel doctrine he says
if you see one of your children that has
passed away it might appear to you in
the form in which you would recognize it
the form of a childhood but if it came
to you as a messenger bearing some
important truth it would perhaps come as
the spirit of bishop edward hunt's son
who died when he was a little child
came to him in the state of a full-grown
manhood
and revealed himself to his father and
said i am your son
so this is a doctrinal teaching like
this is
a common occurrence that mormons see
i've had
i've had a lot of people that i know in
the church
tell me they've had these type of
encounters and i think part of this is
you're you're presupposing your mind to
it because you believe in that so
if the enemy can use that as an angle it
works he's going to use whatever works
to get you
he doesn't care whether his media he
doesn't care whether it's a loved one um
whatever works the enemy doesn't really
care so
but the idea that you would have
visitations from dead people
is right within the culture of the
church
wow so um
another one that's kind of interesting
is the idea that christ will reign on
the earth
so he's actually going to reign on earth
itself um again which is interesting so
article of faith one of the the key
beliefs there that we mentioned when
they were doing it
we believe in the literal gathering of
israel and the restoration of the 10
tribes not 12
10 tribes the zion the new jerusalem
will be
built upon the american continent
catch the word america on american
continent that christ will reign
personally upon the earth and that the
earth will be renewed and receive its
paradistical glory
so this is like pre-heaven america so
this is what's really confusing because
if you read the book of mormon it
descends
if you read the articles of faith it's
built
which is it wow really and so this gets
confusing once again and the idea and
it's going to be built
have you ever really done the math on
the dimensions of this thing it's like
the size of the united states
isn't it like 375 miles it's enormous so
this was a picture of a box on the earth
that's there just to give you some kind
of
yeah it's a little a little bit large to
be building
um does the bible tell us where it's
gonna descend doesn't it descend like
on a specific area that's not in america
no so if you're wondering who the 10
tribes were i always get that question
when
this comes up the 10 lost tribes were
the 10 of the tribes of his ancient
israel that were said to have been
deported from the kingdom israel after
its conquest
um so you've got the reference there so
it's the tribes of ruben
simeon dan naftali gad asher issachar
zebulun
manasseh and ephraim so they have these
what's interesting is this is where
they're going to build it
i got a picture point what what
construction start
uh yeah really why would mitt romney
have done if he would have gotten a
presidency
i don't would we have started starting
the building it's like crazy records
yeah instead of the wall it's like we're
building the city guys so it's not in
production yet no so this is a picture
of the valley of adam ondi amman
so this is the adamic language for the
the name that they gave it
so here's the reference from doctrines
of salvation it says in accordance with
the revelations given to the prophet
joseph smith we teach that the garden of
eden
was on the american continent located
where the city of zion or the new
jerusalem will be built
when adam and eve were driven out of the
garden they eventually dwelt
at a place called adam ondi aman
situated in what is now
davies county missouri dude you want to
head you want to have something
just head to missouri man real estate
buddy
i don't remember where you could live
next to the new jerusalem man
um out there like where is davies county
in missouri is it central is it
honestly i don't know i pulled up a
picture of it you can look it up but
yeah
we'll put the map on right now yeah
so this is i mean i'm just reading what
they
say um these are these are their
references and so there's the plaque and
everything if you want to go there to
see it so
to me yeah the doctrines of salvation
may not be a standard work per se
but the fact that they put memorial
signs up to memoriate it and memorialize
it
yeah it's pretty oh wow yeah i lived i
lived
decently near there oh cool i moved out
at the wrong time
you did so it's just kind of fascinating
because all of a sudden you have this
new concept so
if if we were to have a false christ
appear on earth to establish his kingdom
who would be prime candidates for you
you see every religion
i mean i'm telling you it is across the
board you see it in buddhism you see it
in the new age you see it in the
muslim world you see it it's a global
thing that they are all looking
for this like christ that's going to
come and establish the kingdom here like
even the evangelical world is like
kingdom now right it's all
the kingdom's going to be built here and
now and yeah but what if you do
like i'm sure they're all not thinking
it's going to be in the same place
most people would point to jerusalem if
they were going to point somewhere they
wouldn't point to missouri they're going
to be like
we got that one wrong i mean it looks
like israel but you know
so you know it's just kind of
fascinating looking at some of these um
the priesthood becomes a big deal
because if you don't have the priesthood
you don't have the right to teach them
interesting so they claim to have the
melchizedek priesthood
which according to the book of hebrews
only jesus does that's right
and so but it's
too there's too many nuances and too
many details so
in order to you can actually have a
patriarchal priesthood or you can have
melchizedek priesthood so every
missionary has the melchizedek
priesthood
ordained upon them and so that gives
them that high level of the priesthood
and so
in order to be taught you have to have
at least a higher level priesthood than
i do
so if you have no priesthood they can
disregard everything you say interesting
that it's like tears you know what i
mean like when has god ever really used
the super learned or the super like you
know
highly educated like he's picked people
that were just the common folk or the
grasshoppers to
achieve just for you guys i can put it
here so you have aaronic or levitical
melchizedek holy priesthood after the
order of the son of god
so once you go to the temple for that
and then patriarchal or abrahamic
so you can be ordained to all of those
things but what happens is
biblical miracles performed by the
prophets and apostles were performed by
the power of the priesthood
including the miracles of jesus who
holds all the keys of the priesthood he
didn't do it because he was god it was
because he had the priesthood
you can see where it's happening and so
it's a very different
structure in the priesthood the
priesthood of all believers
uh-uh that's how you strip away the
power
no when you want to maintain the power
you hold the keys to the priesthood
wow so this is where it's key and i
don't know that you want to put any of
that in there because it's really
complicated yeah
um but they believe you can actually be
born into it like aaron did and all
these different things so
um and you can start at age 12 once
you're
worthy enough and blacks weren't allowed
in it until 1978 because it's the mark
of the beast
wow the mark of the beast
both okay depending on which source so
that would start a firestorm yes that
will start a firestorm and i'm not gonna
go there
wow but to if you were gonna be fair to
it
in the 1800s many many many christian
church taught the same thing
yeah because it was in the age of
slavery yeah so when they were trying to
describe where they came from
so there was a mark put on cain to
distinguish him so people would know and
so they say they the
churches baptist and other churches
taught them if it was black skin
they quickly changed that but the mormon
church held onto it the longest
so okay we're going to go again yeah
all right so one of the other unique
doctrinal teachings is
how have you got so you've already seen
some of the nuances of how god changes
now when we get into these it gets
we're going to have some scripture some
joseph smith and it just i'm trying to
give you a picture of where their
doctrine leads
people to believe so i'm going to start
with scripture
because it really paints god the father
in a very different picture
so according to doctrine and covenants
the father is a body of flesh and bones
as tangible as man's the son also but
the holy ghost
has not a body of flesh and bones but is
the personage of spirits where not so
the holy ghost could not dwell in us
logical that's how they do it but joseph
smith
he was a very bold person in the way he
spoke so he said we have imagined
and supposed that god was god from all
eternity
he says i will refute that idea and take
away the veil so that you may see
this is joseph smith the proclaimed
prophet that everybody loves
these are incomprehensible ideas to some
but they are simple it is the first
principle of the gospel to know for
certain the character of god
and to know that we may converse with
him as one man converses with another
and that he was once a man like us
this is the father wow yea that god the
father of us all dwelt on
an earth the same as jesus christ
himself did and i will show it from the
bible now i've read the whole passage he
does
not show it from the bible because you
can't
but that's um this is how he taught so
he's saying you've
imagined that god has always been god
god has not always been god
right wow so the idea of an omnipotent
god that has
always been all-powerful no he was a
human like you and like
me and that's how we can become gods
because you have to bring god down to
our level yep
right so when you bring god down to our
level then we can bring us up to god's
level
um and so they take even the father
and denote him wow so the idea is you
end up getting something like a
genealogy of god's
so jesus is god but so was his father
and so was his father and his father and
his father all on different earths
so you have this ridiculous amount of
time children of god
yeah so when you get into the idea like
you asked me about creation
which creation gotcha so
yeah it just got more complicated the
whole cookie kind of crumbles from
yeah so this is one of them and this was
from a byu professor of religion and
this is where i'm going to say this
isn't
one of their mainstream ideas but it
shows you where they can go so
and we saw a little bit of this in that
diagram it says through modern
revelation we learned that the universe
is filled with vast number of
intelligences that's what we were before
spirit babies
and we further learned that elohim is
god simply because all of these
intelligence
intelligences honor and sustain him but
since god acquired the honor and
sustaining influence of all things it
follows as a corollary that if he should
ever do anything to violate the
confidence
or sense of justice of these
intelligence they would promptly
withdraw their support and the power of
god would disintegrate
he would cease to be god our heavenly
father can
only do those things which the
intelligences under him are voluntarily
willing to support him in accomplishing
byu professor anybody can be god as long
as you're worshipped where can
anybody so when you have the power
to control people you become god so like
celebrities they're
god's baby they are a god in their own
life that's not like some mk
ultra stuff so
it's really bizarre because again i'm
just trying to give you a picture of
where a doctrine can lead you and
sometimes we don't really
think through our doctrine all the way
from start to finish and we can even
have inconsistencies in our own mind and
beliefs
but here if you really believe you can
become god and god was once not
god right what makes him god right
that's what i was thinking
and so all of a sudden you have
completely redefined god and i don't
want to believe in a god
that i could just simply stop worshiping
he ceased to be god then then what
well the majority what happens when
there is god how does this work
yeah i mean if you look at that then
look at the days of noah when only eight
people worship god
right he had to get rid of them to keep
his godly hood he had to get rid of the
ones that didn't worship him
and say now population what happens is
you you have completely redefined all
theology
all theology based on all protestant
religions
even catholic religion any any christian
denomination
of any sort would look at that and go
blasphemy
now i see your point in saying are they
christian
you know what i mean like when jesus was
accused of blasphemy
it was because he was claiming to have
the power and authority of god
right okay when they say they're
becoming gods
right what does that mean so
it it's this really and i feel bad even
bringing it up but this is what
scripture says
i mean it is blasphemy to believe in
these doctrines
as they are believed if you really
believe this
book in the bible is true and so for for
someone of the church of jesus christ
latter-day saints as we're often
calling mormon here just because it's
easier off the tongue i guess
um if you're gonna say i believe in the
bible and the book of mormon
you can't right you really can't do that
you're gonna have to discredit one to
believe in the other that's why you
can't take this
one and have a conversation with a
mormon about it it's a totally different
foundation that's why i started with
showing how they did that and so when
you have a totally different foundation
this view of god is gonna completely
contradict the view of god in their
other scriptures
so who god is what is his plan of
salvation
what is your purpose is your purpose
becoming a god is your purpose becoming
a child of god that worships god
because of what he's done for you i mean
it's a very different dynamic
right i mean completely different
dynamic and so when you do that
you know are you christian i don't know
um it's in the name
but we need to talk about who god the
son is
right because it's in the name because
it's in the name who are they talking
about and so
uh this you're gonna have to forgive me
on here these
this just shows you what happens when
you try and take god and make him man
in the in the literal sense that it's a
man that's becoming god like we can
become god so what happens is then you
take
humanistic tendencies and norms
and you place them on god in not i mean
we have a high priest that can
understand because he was tempted in all
ways like we are but they're taking it
to a different level
and so here in their
journal of discourse as well as a number
of places you can find that jesus was
not begotten by the holy ghost the birth
of the savior was as natural
as are the births of our children it was
the result of natural action
so the immaculate conception nope wow
so who was his earthly father so
you start seeing the complication the
breaking down of christian theology
the prophecies about jesus coming as oh
god all gone
and so if the acts of jesus were written
according to orson pratt and the
bookseer we no doubt should learn that
these beloved women mary martha and mary
magdalene were his wives he was a
polygamous wow
and so da vinci code multiplied
kind of concept going on here and so
when joseph fielding smith he's kind of
their greatest theologian
was asked if jesus was in fact married
he answered yes but don't preach
it wow so because it's going to confuse
people
the thing is yes they believe it in a
sense but they don't preach it and
this is why you get people that are um
internet christians people that read
this stuff and they're like whoa
no way but these are good people at the
church i like these people these are
family
we have good family values we do all
these fun things together
daddy daughter night family home evening
all these different things and it's like
this is great
i'm not going to give all that up just
because there were some crazy prophets
back in the
back days wow so this is where you start
getting classifications that are totally
different that's why i go through that
in the beginning because
i mean who's going to read that most
mormons would read that and say
man that's just blasphemy why did why
are you even bringing that up
that's not something we believe and i
get it but this is where your theology
leads
so this is what i'm saying this is what
happens when you embrace
the other elements that are really clear
in scripture they begin to
like anybody you read scripture and you
begin to interpret it and you get
insights and you bounce it off here and
there and you form beliefs
they've done that and this is the kind
of places it leads you can understand
the trajectory if you will you can
understand why
the the one um quote that you read at
the very beginning of this was saying
like
this is either a totally you know
designed thing or if it's not true this
is
evil and malicious and deceiving in
their own words
this is where it goes so i wish i was
stopping there
so gospel principles as well as gospel
through the ages says
jesus is the literal spirit brother of
lucifer a creation
wow so he's the spirit brother of lucy
if we were all spirits in heaven from
the same father then we'd be sewered
brothers and sisters right
and so lucifer becomes the sibling in a
sense
and if you read in moses it's very
fascinating the passage i didn't bring
my
mormon scriptures with me but it says
and i the lord god spoken to moses
saying satan whom thou hast
commanded he came before me saying
behold here i am send me i will be thy
son and
i will redeem all mankind that not one
soul shall be lost and surely i will do
it
wherefore give me this thine honor and
what happens if you read the dialogue on
this is a jacob esau story wow it's the
younger trying to
usurp the older's place and satan wanted
to be our savior
oh wow so he's not really the enemy
he's really our savior wannabe wow
this is right in scripture this is the
pearl of great price so this is the
dialogue that happens there and so
it's kind of mind-blowing it's hard to
wrap your mind around a little bit
like the implications then of going to
hell like well
did he get angry later on is it really
not that bad because
well remember their diagram it's just a
detour for a thousand years right
and isn't that even one more slam where
he's like i wanted to save
everybody but jesus won't save everybody
i will save everybody you know what i
mean it's like
like as if god doesn't care about
everyone
and this is one of their standard works
wow
so i mean as you go on it just it's like
wow and we already kind of talked about
this whole concept of becoming gods i
read this quote from the gordon b
hinckley
brigham young also said he went so far
the idea of becoming god or exalted as
the term used in their scripture
he went so far as to say we can become
king of kings and lord of lords
or father of fathers or prince a
princess name's only reserved for jesus
so again you have this idea when you
when you say we can be exalted and
become
god and man was god and god is man i
mean
you get all these confused and all of a
sudden
i mean how more how much more
blasphemous could you be according to
scripture
you know we we've talked about um uh
christ consciousness
on this show lots you know that's kind
of what uh uh oprah winfrey's hammering
app
that's what she has eckhart tolle on her
show and stuff that's that's basically
what he's getting at
is is that you can become this
you know this kind of god or whatever
like that so you can see how
even a lot of these deceptions that are
in our world have these overlapping
teachings they do
that that you see a thread through a lot
of different
variety of teachings you can see many of
these beliefs it's kind of a melting pot
of many things so you can see
links to islam multiple levels levels of
heaven
women wear wear modest clothing i mean
you've got uh
you know virgins and heaven
all these different things in that you
you've got cause i've lived in taiwan
i've served amongst buddhists i've
worked with
hindus muslims and they they all have
similarities to what i grew up with
and they would even go on joseph so much
so so if it's all human and it's just a
creation he then goes to have humans
involved in creation
wow so he goes in to say joseph milling
said
it is true that adam helped to form this
earth he labored with
our savior jesus christ i have a strong
viewer conviction that there were others
who were also assisting him noah enoch
why not joseph smith and those who were
appointed to be rulers of the earth
before it was formed so there were
people rulers that were meant to be
rulers of the earth before the earth was
formed they were
pre-appointed to be rulers and here they
help them create
creation no put me in my body
is this joseph smith speaking in third
person no this is his son
but he's their greatest theologian okay
so he wrote more
theology than most of their other
prophets so
it's just it's wild where it can take
you
and so again they can they could
probably discredit this say it's not one
of the founding works but i mean come on
this is where it kind of leads this is
what happens you're taking and
warping the view of god to such an
extent that
what's the difference you've stripped
away creation
that's why the bible says if it speak
not according to
this word it is because there is no
light in it so and that's one of the
things that
where you know there were biblical tests
of a prophet
prophets had to meet certain criterium
to qualify and there was false prophets
clear through scripture jeremiah has a
whole bunch of them for example
and they made predictions that didn't
come true and all these different things
so there were qualifications
because if a prophet is going to be
deemed as a prophet we have to test
things to see if they are true so here
we've taken the prophet and made them
the test of everything
besides them so they flipped the role of
where the test comes
so that way a prophet doesn't have to be
tested by anything and the prophets can
contradict each other and the prophets
can change things and
you're taking on basically what you do
with this is you end up worshiping
humanity
yeah you're worshiping man the image
not the creator so
this is kind of what it takes this is a
famous doctrine um
from i i'm reluctant to bring this in
as well but it's the idea that adam was
actually god himself
oh wow so the idea that you can worship
man
it says when our father adam came into
the garden of eden he came in
with his celestial body and brought eve
one of his wives
no room with him he helped to make and
organize this world he is michael
the archangel the ancient of days about
whom holy men have written and spoken he
is our father and our god and the only
god
with whom we have to do so god is god
adam and michael
we're worshiping man and it's the good
men
that become gods wow
wow and those that have gone ahead of us
say up to a profit level they're the
ones that can dictate
reality wow you know this is like
setting people up can you imagine in the
end of time
if all of a sudden seriously the spirits
start coming out
and they're like posing as the prophets
or whatever
i mean you've got a whole swath of
church members that are literally like
oh wow this is the prophecy you should
come back to tell us the truth
you're done you're toast to this it
doesn't matter if it contradicts this
because everything they believe
does that's right so one of the things
that's really confusing about mormons is
they take christian terminology and they
twist it redefine it we call that
gnosticism yes
so what happens is you can have a
conversation with a mormon missionary
and feel like
man yeah we're right on the same page
over and over and over again
and it means something totally different
wow so
for example salvation is not by faith
alone sola
um scriptura sola fida this idea that
it's by faith alone
gone wow so and they actually have two
different kinds of salvation
so this quote hurts my head a little bit
but it's i'm going to try and read it
slowly and help you guys to wrap my mind
your
mind what they mean because their
salvation is not exactly the same and
this is how everybody can be saved
wow universalism if you will so they
have conditional
or individual salvation two different
kinds of salvation
that which comes by grace coupled with
gospel obedience
aka works consistent receiving an
inheritance in the celestial kingdom
however those who do not go on to
exaltation
godhood will have immortality only and
not eternal life
interesting yeah can you follow that no
immortality
only and not eternal life wow so
let let me unpack that a little bit that
means you can't have seed
you can't continue to have offspring in
heaven as an interesting
oh wow so taking the seed away
takes away that so you can tell eternal
life is you have life coming to man came
over this religion because he's just
like you're not gonna
be able to repopulate plural
there's actually if you go through the
doctrine and covenants when joseph smith
first had the revelation of polygamy
um he actually has a whole chapter
cursing his first
wife because she was resisting him and
it's still there
wow so women's rights activists i don't
know how they read that without
screaming
because it's it's writing scripture wow
so
here it says they will live us this
punishment having
immortality says they will live
separately and singly in an unmarried
state
so you're going to be single for the
rest of your life if you don't do all
the works
full salvation is attained by virtue of
knowledge truth
righteousness and all true principles
without the atonement
the gospel the priesthood and the
sealing power there would be no
salvation
without continuous revelation that's the
idea of always having a prophet
there would be no salvation if it had
not been for joseph smith and the
restoration
there would be no salvation there is no
salvation outside
of the church of jesus christ of
latter-day saints
so do you realize how difficult it is to
have salvation now wow
it's hard to be saved right that's
a little bit different one thing they
they act like being forever single
is the worst curse that can possibly
happen yet that's exactly what jesus
said would happen to us in our
resurrected bodies you'll become like
the angels and either giving in marriage
so they're saying that the i know what
is actually truth is the biggest curse
you could so that's part of the curse
now do you see why they could say he was
married
so again all these little things they
start connecting the dots all over and
so
even if it's not a source that they
necessarily are like yeah that scripture
is embedded in the theology that is
there
and so they go on so there there's no
salvation outside the church hence
baptisms for the dead all these things
being good by saving people through
these things but it says
unconditional or general salvation that
which comes by grace
alone without obedience to gospel law
consists in the mere fact
of being resurrected so a mormon
missionary can tell you you're saved by
grace through faith alone
and you're going to be resurrected to
which resurrection
hmm yeah
[Laughter]
[Applause]
there's more than one resurrection in
scripture right right that's true
so there's a resurrection of the just
and the unjust
and so this type of salvation is
not what you think it is because they
have full salvation
and partial salvation so it says this
kind of salvation
eventually will come to all mankind
how can you say that when you say in the
very same sentence that if you are not
a mormon you cannot be saved like how
can you say this is
and then salvation will come to you
everywhere simple work in genealogy
you have to make everybody that's ever
lived have the opportunity to be mormon
we have to make god fair wow
because if that's true if you have to be
more mormon to be saved
we've got to go to every single person
that ever
lived before joseph smith yeah what and
give them the option why wouldn't we
have just like a voting booth you know
like everybody just show up and
like check off the box and then you're
good like so the
implications of who god is and the
character of god
totally changed what a finicky god
wow and they will actually go in i mean
they talk about
uh this dark ages where truth was lost
there was literally people couldn't be
saved the truth wasn't on the earth
wow sorry you're born in the wrong age
tough luck
yeah i mean really i mean what kind of
god is this
wow so i mean it just it paints a very
different picture um
so that's that's what they call the
great apostasy and the restoration of
the gospel and again this is straight
from mormon.org their their website
this is kind of that dark ages kind of
thing it says according to mormons
following the death of jesus christ
wicked people persecuted and killed many
church members
and other church members drifted from
the principles taught by jesus christ
and his apostles
the apostles were killed and the
priesthood authority which
becomes a key thing for them and i don't
have time to unpack it all but it's
where they get their authority including
the keys to direct and receive
revelation for the church so the the
spirit of prophecy is a
key that's linked to priesthood
and so that's where this kind of comes
in
because the church was no longer led by
priesthood authority in revelation error
crept into the church teachings
so the assumption is as if the
priesthood authority's there no error
can come in
so you become a perfect church good
people
and much truth remained but the gospel
as established by jesus christ was lost
resulting in a period called the great
apostasy
some inspired people such as martin
luther or john calvin
recognized that practices and doctrines
had been changed or lost
and tried to reform the churches to
which they belonged without the
priesthood authority however
christ's gospel could not be returned to
its original form
wow so all protestants are wrong in that
sense
even though they tried you didn't have
the authority
and what happens in joseph smith's story
is he actually had angelic beans come
down and
lay hands on him and give him the
authority
there's a there's a statue in salt lake
city you can see that so
but this this ends up making it so
people there's
times when people couldn't be lost
desert news is their official press it
says at various times in history of the
world
opportunity for mankind to receive the
blessings of the gospel has been denied
them
god wouldn't give them the good news for
instance during
the time of apostate the opportunity for
men to receive the remission of their
sins
by baptism and partake of the ordinance
essential to
exaltation was impossible the church
without its authorized minister was not
on the earth
it is the true is it it is true and that
similar conditions have existed at other
more remote periods of time so
in other words god was a little bit
picky and choosy on when you could be
saved when you couldn't be saved
i think when you look at the history of
the reformation you can see
that god has always had a some true
people exactly some true people that are
really
um sharing his truth i mean to the point
where
they would put them in their garments
yeah and you would die if you got caught
with it
yeah the wall dancing stitching in their
clothes all kinds of different groups
really held on to different parts of
truth and had the truth
maintaining even though the existing
church may have gone away that didn't
mean
god said okay sorry that's that's like
elijah i'm the only one god
and he says no i got a few others yeah
so they're saying that there were times
periods generations where that nobody
were nobody could be saved
but did they worship they didn't worship
god so god ceased to be god god's truth
was
it didn't matter wow so and this is part
of why
you know like i mentioned the priesthood
becomes a big deal because if you don't
have the priesthood you can't teach them
anything
wow so it kind of ties in everywhere but
this is this idea and it's right in
their key beliefs so they believe joseph
smith
had the fullness of the gospel of jesus
christ and it was restored
that comes through the book of mormon in
the new testament about jesus coming to
the americas and so
it's just kind of fascinating to go
through um
cut that yeah
um there's a lot more i could say but we
should probably stop
or yeah come to a conclusion at some
point which is awesome yeah
no this this this really was um you know
i think
very enlightening like i actually had no
idea
of what they actually really believed
now i've seen i've seen people rip
on other churches and you know like try
to point all this stuff out and it's
like you know i've even seen some
some about uh various churches where i
go that's not
that's not what they believe but but
when you see it at this
level coming from their own publications
their own website
that that that is pretty interesting to
me that that's one of the things i tried
to do because
i i grew up with this stuff but i needed
to find out where it came from
why we believed in it and you got to
give heart to
a mormon that tries to leave this um
i will at my own brother-in-law um i
don't know if he would like me sharing a
story per se but the idea was
he left the church he decided he was a
bishop
he was high up in the church and he
decided he'd come across some of these
things he left
his parents disowned him said you're not
our son
so there's extreme
things that can come with doing this um
i've worked with them
when i i had a couple attending some
meetings i was giving one of them was
highly convicted
and the spouse was very upset that they
were entertaining these new ideas new
doctrines and so
they went to the bishop the bishop said
take the kids and leave them and teach
them a lesson for entertaining such
heresy
i mean i don't know about you if my wife
took my kids
that's pretty close to home that's
pretty hard that's pretty hardcore so
they they have no problem and i had
another lady that
you know he told her you know you need
to go pray about this and
let god convict you whether the truth of
mormonism is there and you'll get a
burning in your bosom that is the truth
and that was what she was told so she
went she prayed about it no burning in
the bosom
burning the bosom is your testimony it's
like religious heartburn if you will
it's you get this burning that it's true
and she didn't and when she went back
the bishop said you need to
really think very seriously about what
you're doing your job
was got to you was provided to you
through church connections
your family your friends are you willing
to give all that
up will you really sacrifice your family
and everybody and everything you know
for the truth that's what jesus asked
wow but are we willing to do it
and so you've got to pray for the people
if you if you're someone's mormon and
listening to this
you've got to realize it's going to be a
struggle and i mean a
real struggle and just to go back on
this burning in the bosom
that seems to be a an impassable thing
because if you have a conviction that
it's the truth how do you deny someone's
conviction
right so the reality is you could say
well
if a catholic which they don't believe
is the true church
has a burning in their bosom that
catholicism is true does that make it
true
yeah yeah yeah yes no wait
uh the thing is is all of a sudden
you're basing truth off of
feeling right and that's always a
dangerous thing so even when you get to
those
because i've worked with people and
tried to help them understand they're
like but i have a burning in the bosom
that this is truth and that
it's like a stop all for everything but
when you stop
step back and look at the rationale
behind this burning in the muslims
shouldn't everyone have a burden in
their bosom that what they believe is
true
otherwise why would you believe it right
so these are kind of some of the
challenges they face they have so many
obstacles and
often when they come to other christian
churches they're like oh
good for you saved out of that cult yeah
have a great life i hope you find jesus
and they've lost their entire
infrastructure family network
everything and they need a lot of
support and help in that regard it's a
lot like
other religions i mean you try to leave
the
islamic sometimes you can be killed yeah
so you're looking at the same thing
maybe not as extreme
in some in the disowning and the cutting
off and the
hardships there's a lot of ties into
that because it's such a tight-knit
community and stuff so it's really
difficult for them to come out and even
if they believe some of these things
many of them will remain
jack mormon because it's like it's just
not worth it
yeah you know what am i going to do i
mean do you give up your wife and kids
i mean what how far can you take this i
mean this is where
the rubber meets the road for a lot of
people this is where the gospel really
better be some good news
right right because if it's not if it
doesn't set you
free you will not be free indeed right
um but it will be if you really embrace
the god of scripture is a beautiful i
believe
the doctrines of the bible when rightly
understood paint the most beautiful
picture of god
right and if you understand them and you
follow them they will keep you from the
last
end time deceptions because they're the
ways that help you understand
what's coming and how not to be saved
but to
stay saved is that fair so we're saved
by grace or faith not by works lest any
man should boast there's ephesians
that's how you're saved but if you
embrace
biblical truth you have joy and peace
that the world doesn't have to offer and
life just gets better and you've got to
check everything through the bible yeah
it's got to come back to scripture
because otherwise yep
it's just your thoughts if you've got
some morphine-changing orbeez
like theology that's kind of like well
it's currently
you know whatever and and you have no
line so here's the line the bible's the
line
i mean that's that's what we hammer on
this show over and over and over again
if you've watched
enough of our shows any of you audience
members out there
this is this is i hope you got a
blessing out of this talk jason thank
you so much for breaking that
down right here brothers and sisters
right here
read the word of god i mean honestly you
should know what this says
if you have a question with anything if
something doesn't sit right with you
counsel that with god go to the bible
and say does this
really speak according to this book
because if it doesn't
trust me there is a wide variety of
distractions that we can get ourselves
into
and also i love how you approach this
topic pray for those brothers and
sisters that are involved in this
you you know you you you hit the nail on
the head these are sweet loving kind
people and we should not be just like
well we know the truth and
and you guys are caught up in an error
do you know what i mean yes please
please on my behalf i just want to say
do not use what i shared with you on
what's wrong with their church
to beat them over the head and belittle
them and undermine them that is not my
intentions at all
yes some of these things sound very
strange very odd
yes but have a dialogue make a
friendship with them
care about them personally before you
start attacking doctrines
when you attack someone's beliefs they
tend to get defensive you need to help
walk them into truth but i share what i
share so you understand where they're
coming from
and what they may go through and the
challenges they're going to face that's
the reason i share it
not so i give you ammunition per se and
that's what people tell me you you
basically started off this conversation
with the pews
study that said mormons already feel
attacked
that's kind of the number one thing is
they were like okay everybody's coming
at us guns blazing this is a cult right
um you know you you you see the evidence
right here
you guys can make up your own mind with
that but that is not how you're gonna
win
a heart and you know what i mean so so
definitely prayerfully if you engage
with a mormon or
you know you you want to talk with you
need to build a friendship build a
friendship that's how
christ's method was he was going to
cultivate the soil before he planted
that seed
and i believe that that's exactly what
we need to do as well jason thank you
for coming
yes and we're actually going to get into
his personal testimony
which i think you guys will totally love
because dude this guy has lived a
crazy life and uh god is good god is
good but it's a testament that god can
pull us out of any
place that we've gotten ourselves into
so thank you guys for watching led live
if you like this video give us a thumbs
up
if you want to share it so other people
can also understand this topic please do
that
and also um yeah check out our website
littlelightstudios.tv we've got
lots of dvds and and documentaries on
various different subjects but
thank you guys for watching thank you
guys for supporting what we do and we'll
see you guys
next friday
um
[Music]
visit our brothers at school for profits
dot tv and watch from babylon to america
which has over 5 million views on
youtube alone
and follow it up with america 2 babylon
check the description below for links to
this and more
[Music]
foreign